mark is with us in Illinois hey Mark
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you so much for taking my call my
pleasure
honored to talk to you okay cool how can
I help ya so I got a question for you to
sell or not to sell
I bought some properties about four
years ago for two hundred seventy five
thousand and I put about three hundred
and twenty thousand denim so I owe about
six hundred thousand we we just had a
person come up to us and ask if they
wanted they wanted to buy these
properties for 1.3 million now so that's
my dilemma we're we're wondering if we
should sell or if we should keep these
or what we're having paid off in seven
years is the plan but we'll be bringing
in about fourteen thousand dollars a
month if I keep them you know so it's
like should I just get the payout now
and be out of debt or simply wait and
you know be making a lot more money in
the future you have any other debt we we
got married two years ago me and my wife
so we have one kid we paid up ninety two
thousand get up all the cars paid off
student loan great um you have any other
that we do have one student loan of
$100,000 loan what's your household
income I do my name's I have a sixty
five thousand a year for that okay and
the business income is about 150,000 a
year profit profit yeah so your
household income taxable to ten yeah my
business LLC so it is uh no I'm talking
about your household income your profit
the LLC's a hundred percent pass through
it is taxable income what profit does it
make what do you pay taxes on in your
house a year sixty five thousand no all
right so it's false and it's my business
is 150 I pay taxes on that I just don't
take an income from my
because I'm putting Paul back into the
business why well just to help it grow
over the last few years to pay the debt
off faster I'm paying more down on on
the debt what I owe to the bank is this
the business that is the property yes oh
so that you're talking about that makes
you a profit of a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year and you've been
using that to reduce the debt on the
property correct and fixing any of the
problems that happen but I don't take
any money from that yet we live here on
the property um so it pays my expenses
but there's you know twelve twelve
parking buildings that we have rented
out
well it's twelve apartments yeah okay so
here's a business lesson your your
income for your home that the the good
that the business do does you is the net
profit of the business so it's the gross
rents collected minus the expenses of
operating the properties is your net
profit okay and so 150 is not correct
because we have expenses to operate the
property 150 is that gross receipts
micro yeah yeah that's okay - your
expenses that you have out of that and
your debt payment is not an expense out
of that but it is a cash flow item out
of that so yeah you just gotta start
getting that part right because I'm
trying to figure out how you're gonna
pay off this hundred grand in student
loan debt right and that's what I'm
after I'm trying to figure out how to do
that I would do that now as far as this
apartment you live in it it sounds like
you've made obviously a really good
investment in the purchase and in the
renovations because you're a Turner your
return is amazingly excellent going from
going from six hundred million three now
so the next question is that property
sitting there for a million three on the
market
would you want to buy it because it's
going to be such a good long-term
investment if you didn't own it yeah
that was my plan from the beginning this
is my retirement plan
you know really I wouldn't I wouldn't
want it to be your retirement plan I
don't want to be part of your wealth
building plan yeah and it worked you
made some good wealth on it and it's
gonna cash flow like a bandit and we can
get it paid off and get your student
loan paid off in just a matter of years
and you're gonna be in really really
good shape I'd keep it yeah yeah I just
think it's good to hear you say that and
we're planning to pay off the student
loans in less than two years with what I
make now it's not sooner you know we
paid off ninety two thousand and less
than nine years I would I would pay
minimum payments on the real estate and
throw all the cash at the student loans
until the student loans are gone okay
that's awesome and then once they're
gone then I would turn around and get
the real estate paid off and let's just
treat this whole thing on the baby steps
but you've done really really well
congratulations it's an excellent
excellent purchase